hi I'm Ryan and tonight I'm gonna be
watching the trailer for sabotage a lot
of people have been asking me to do this
trailer and I been wanting to I really
have I just haven't had the time to get
around to it you know I'm a busy guy you
think I got five minutes out of my day
to watch a trailer come on that's all I
do all day like my house is a dump right
now and I could be cleaning but instead
i'm going to do this it's rated R for
strong bloody violence pervasive
language some sexuality some is always
good nudity and drug use hi sounds like
my kind of movie hey now Oh Oh Arnold
you are back in good old fashioned my
friend it's a long time to learn
who the [ __ ] drunk ass house me Chris
thank you shut the [ __ ] up he's such a
shitty actor shut up oh god I'm taking a
shot good job I want to watch them so
bad now Oh
alright today's did these yeah men be
men today of a major cartel leader has
led to a seizure of hundreds of millions
of dollars hey Neilly wake up you're
drunk [ __ ]
tote sounds like he's forcing those
lines whoa I gotta ask you a few
questions ten million dollars is missing
from your cartel bust did you steal it
no [ __ ] you for asking happened on my
watch the cartel thinks you stole my
money
how do you wake up there oh did you show
that he gets killed off every bezel oh
no he's the understanding over your
[ __ ] head
yeah cartel is to find out who stole
money it could be someone on my team one
of my own people can't trust these man
it's you or it's grinder for sugar or my
dear loving husband [ __ ] crazy is she
any other friends getting smoked help Oh
wife and kid I'm sorry they always get
the action heroes wife and kid destroy
them that's when he gets to the finale
yeah this looks badass
oh I got chills all over my body
the two terminators on screen
all right all right I won't learn
[ __ ] restaurant
no we are not alone
yes yes that is so much better than the
actual trailer they have playing in
theaters and [ __ ] the you know domestic
crap the red band trailer whoa if the
movies like that serious but fast pacing
and kind of cheesy but bad acid the same
if it's if it's all those things then
[ __ ] yeah I'm on board like by far I
really hope this gets at least like a
sixty-seven percent on rotten tomatoes
if it's around there i'm definitely
going if it's not i'm still probably
going to go that's just the way I
operate I love on a Larkin Arnold's
[ __ ] awesome man everything we had
like that whole TV problem [ __ ] but I
still think Arnold's a [ __ ] awesome
dude such nobody does but he's also
really good at it